let's talk about the big uh the big news
here check this out we got the story
from the daily mail
driving a hard bargain haulage firms
offer a hundred thousand dollar salaries
and fifteen thousand dollar bonuses to
lure eighty thousand truckers and ease
supply crisis as empty shipping
containers are dumped in the streets
because california port is full
this is a trucker problem check this out
they say near the ports of los angeles
and long beach transportation execs say
the problem isn't a lack of drivers it's
mass congestion caused by empty
containers
steam ships are refusing to take back
empty containers and charging trucking
companies a per diem to store them that
is what is driving some small businesses
to close the logistical situation at the
po as the ports worsen head of the
california trucking association has
called for a state of emergency to be
imposed it all ties to supply chain
chaos that's left cargo ships queuing
for weeks to unload goods to truck uh to
trucking companies which are unable to
effectively move them so christmas
canceled what's going on they can't get
that little stretch they're dumping way
more than uh containers in the streets
of california have you been to san
francisco
right now sitting in front of a city
hall right now is doing a different type
of dumping
but uh
i i told you tim you signed up for this
now back on this topic um
let's get back to dumping
yes i think it's also important to point
out that a lot of container ships don't
want to go back with empty containers
because they don't get paid for shipping
nothing and there's no reason for them
to go back and forth when they have
nothing to ship back one of the reasons
they have nothing to ship back is
because of the slowdown and destruction
of manufacturing in this country but
also the fact that there's a lockdown
those lockdowns that happened months ago
almost a year ago the the ramifications
of it are being felt right now now what
happens now it's not just going to play
out for christmas it's going to play out
beyond that because we're talking about
consumer goods not just for you know
chinese made slave made good toys for
your child we're talking about tools
we're talking about essential items that
other businesses need to create
different kind of products to put
products together so all of that is
going to be in in disrepair to the point
where even florida has just announced
that they're going to be opening up
their ports and a lot of ships are
considering literally going through the
panama canal into florida as florida has
announced hey this is a crisis we could
help fix it let's bring all the goods
here we could ship them around the
country but the the crisis here there's
many layers to it because it's not just
a labor shortage it's not just a trucker
shortage it's also
emission laws that the governor of
california has put that has limited the
specific trucks that could move in the
specific ships that could move in as
well it's also the vax mandates that
specifically make sure that a lot of
people can't work when they want to work
and it's also people saying hey
the dollar is not worth crap the
government is hyperinflating it it's
printing it out of thin air it's not
worth nothing why should i work when i
can't even afford uh
to live when gas is skyrocketing up in
california you know what people don't
realize
is that when these shipping containers
can't make it in these companies have
started contracting private vessels to
like trying you know private ports and
stuff like that and so now we're hearing
that what would normally cost like 2
grand in shipping is going to cost 10
times that 20 25
that means your products are going to go
up not just because of demand but
because of this the supply chain
breaking is increasing the cost of
shipping tenfold that's going to come
down in this product
now check us out in this daily mail
article they actually show this this
doll this is the this is the craziest
thing about it look at this let me see
if we can scroll down
this is an american girls sold out
blonde winter princess doll retailed for
250 bucks is now going for up to a
thousand dollars on platforms such as
mercari and ebay whoa
yeah wow i mean they're even talking
about bringing in the national guard to
help them get rid of these cargo ships
but but but again they're going to
offload the cargo ships where are they
going to put all the empty containers
exactly and the global supply chain
again it runs on its own kind of
volition uh it's not centrally
controlled it's not organized it runs
when there's a need for it now if
there's nothing going back there's no
point for people even shipping things in
so there's a lot of chaos a lot of
disarray and everything that happened
has a
direct fingerprint of the government
intervening saying that they're going to
help everyone when they're causing these
problems and only exacerbating them that
much worse yeah you will own nothing and
you will be happy exactly this is a part
in my opinion the great reset and
screwing people over this is what you
got to understand about stuff like when
the government gets involved when you
you can tell they're applying a pressure
in some way they're not going to come
out right and be like we're shutting
down the port because people would
revolt
but you throw some sticks and stones in
the way some wrenches and some spokes
make it a lot harder for businesses to
operate and then you watch them slowly
struggle out and then gasp their last
breath and then their store closes down
and then there you go you will own
nothing this is like another iteration
of the lockdown that predominantly helps
out the big billionaire class and screws
everyone else over because when the
average business relies on these kind of
shipping containers amazon walmart
costco they just they they get their own
ships they literally are able to skirt
these rules and they're able to play by
different set of rules meanwhile
everyone else is screwed here saying hey
i don't have much options here except
for paying a thousand dollars for a doll
that's 250 yeah people might be
wondering why luke's so angry it's you
know luke actually uh stopping hints he
wanted the american girl people did yeah
i did my christmas shopping a couple
weeks ago i was telling my audience
members i was like you should do that
too kamala harris out of all people uh
actually had a uh a moment where she had
some kind of clarity and actually told
people a few weeks ago hey you should do
your christmas shopping now no she's a
conspiracy theorist yeah she's just
trying to she's pushing mlm or something
she's she's trying to griff i can't
stand her she talks to you like you're
like a kid in a gardener you ever notice
that like hi how are you doing i imagine
if somebody talked to you like that i
mean like who is this did you see her
she arrived at her own surprise party
and yelled surprise
no wait yes
it's white house
white house videos
so we could play it there's no there
shouldn't be any copyright issues with
it but uh i mean just
this is the perfect epitome of of who is
trying to control you the representation
of just
utter insincere knowledge
people want to be talked to like that
are they like go ahead
[Music]
so wait kamala harris surprised them
like they did they didn't know what they
were doing
no i mean obviously i think she just
nervously dropped the ball i think it's
funnier to imagine that they were like
everybody you are here by you by are
here by working they're just at lunch
at all no no they're like you are hereby
required to be in the cafeteria it's
like what are we for it's mandatory and
they're all standing there and then come
on surprise she's fake you're having a
party for me it's like the most staged
yeah she just can't be human that's the
problem she could do she might not be
human
at this point i mean did you see that
video that she did with uh youtube
specials say it again she she did a
video with uh i think it was was it
discovery or youtube tv uh where she was
the nasa thing where she sat down with
kids and actually like she was going
blind uh yeah it wasn't her wasn't there
a child actor that yeah they had
actors and she was just going so they
have to stage real life and it wasn't
biden on a stage did you guys ever oh
yeah yeah
they built i mean it looks like the
white house did we ever have a president
that did that or is that typical or is
that a new thing i never i don't i don't
know i don't think i don't i don't think
that's i mean it's new it's all in front
of our face guys
and it's like we just don't want to
realize like it's a show i mean how much
more where's the strings behind them
someone was probably hanging over that
thing with marinette's aliens aliens
could be yeah what did you say
struggles to be hold on now you can't
you can't say the word alien because
demi lovato says that it's you know
discriminatory
terrestrial
now she's just a nut case yeah yeah so
she's the one she's the one that uh
she's no lady gaga or beyonce so her
opinion is nothing she's the one that
lady gaga came out right she's the one
that shamed the frozen yogurt place
that's right for uh having too many diet
options for her and ruining her week
yeah yeah a person with 100 million
people following and she shames a small
business during the height of a pandemic
she could buy 10 of those you know
frozen yogurt places and then do
whatever she wants and said she just
wants to just be mean yeah i'm i'm just
waiting for her to identify as froyo
yeah because she's they now right and
then she says i might be end up being
trans well she she got attacked she got
slammed by the left for that did she
yeah because they were saying that she
was she was like just trying to use it
as a marketing style absolutely so she
actually got
yeah that was that was a very quick
segue off of supply
have you seen her recently she was
caught with uh paris hilton in hollywood
she looks like a uh a plumber from
arkansas i don't know if you want to
pull that up it's bad it's really i mean
i'm not kidding no enough about demi
lovato to care to be honest well this is
the problem people i don't want to know
any of this stuff but people send me all
this crap you know what i mean and i i
like again this is the downside to being
a idiocracy historian or whatever you
want to call me is i i have to look at
this stuff i do this for you guys we
appreciate it yeah i hope so
so i'll tell you what that's why i'm
drinking now this is really good
you